we all have masks we all try to find the
special things inside of us but when you
get to sit in a chair like in like in
Batman Returns and have some artist like
mess you up it's like really cool it's
like when you know when you put on a
costume where you go again Halloween or
anything like that it's kind of you have
this freedom the Cuckoo's Nest Ken
Kesey's book One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest
and I was fortunate to do the play off
Broadway like they did the plane on
Broadway years ago and then in 1970 I
think they did it in San Francisco we
revived it by that time all the
everybody was hip to Kesey's work and
they really appreciated the fact that
what was going on in the country
they weren't staying in hospitals people
were giving them drugs you know
outpatient kind of stuff anyway I did
the play off Broadway and then in 1974 I
did the movie and that was with Mila
Forman directing it even though
Nicholson and I were born in the same
hospital and as in New Jersey in Neptune
New Jersey I was I lived in Asbury we'd
never met but I used to hear about him
all the time when I was a kid his sister
and my sister were both in the beauty
but there were inherent hairdressers and
then one day you know I I saw one of his
movies right in the drive-in movie
theater and I said this guy ain't so
good you know nobody was any way during
Cuckoo's Nest at 74 is when we first met
and that was was it was a fun trip I had
a great time too martini martinis whole
thing was that he was a pilot in the war
and he was shot down and and he was in
water and everything was sinking so if
you notice in the movie besides being
like really very agreeable really good
guy and enjoying the company of
everybody like always wanted causative
that was part of the smile that was
going on
I also sat on my feet I was on a piece
of furniture sitting on a chair on the
armed when we playing cards or if I was
in the group therapy
I always wrapped myself up in my feet
because as the tension built that was
like part of the idea the water rising
when I that kept coming back if I can't
hit you because it ain't your turn yet I
understand you see these other people
these are the real these are real people
here so that was more TV taxi actually
was like a kind of a gift in a way it
was 1978 I done Cuckoo's Nest was in the
movie theaters already it was in 75 I
think and was really a big hit and you
know I was in the is kind of like
juncture of like one a direct one of act
I couldn't you know you actors you can't
find it it's really difficult to find a
job basically we're all looking for work
you know that was yes he did everything
like to policewoman and I did a Starsky
and Hutch I think I did gone south which
was a movie that Jack directed casting
director seduces once you guys doing
this thing that were from The Mary Tyler
Moore Show now I not being a television
free especially in that era because it
was you know how looking for work all
the time with acting I didn't watch all
these The Mary Tyler Moore Show in room
222 and whatever they you know Brooks
Jim Brooks and Ed Weinberger stand
Daniels but it didn't really resonate
with me because I had never watched so
casting director says you got it this
part is like amazing he should go and I
I I said okay and I went in and I read
the script it was like a great part
really can't tankers telling people
looked at the book don't put your hands
like that perchance down okay telling
people what to do you know who is like
in that spot we turn take the hat off
this kind of stuff you know all that so
I figured to get this part I wanted to
do something really you know someday
would remember me died so I walked in
with the script and they were all
sitting around and I said one thing I
want to know before we start who wrote
this [ __ ] and I threw it on a coffee
table
and there was this moment of Terror
where I just walked and then all of a
sudden like everybody just laughed their
asses off and from that moment on like
when when I was in the audience I mean
anything I said was they found funny you
know like I said and so it was like
really a cool way to get apart one time
with that backfired on me but that's a
whole of the story there was a guy doing
a movie not know what play and I'd seen
a play that he directed and I thought
the best thing to do it would be to do
something crazy
to go in I did something really wacky
and I didn't get the part so it doesn't
always work yes I was great well you
know the whole thing about that being a
gift I said it before but the idea is
that you know we were all out there
looking for the thing you know and you
can do tons and tons of parts and you
can be good you got to be prepared so
you go you that's what you to classes
you do everything acting studies all the
things that you do in all the little
parts then once in a while you get lucky
I got really fortunate because at that
moment that character came along louise
de palma it was like a god it's your
mother calling
she says somebody's trying to break into
her apartment now get back to it
at that time there were three networks
ABC CBS NBC and everybody watched
television at that time and I don't
think this matters you understand this
but there's a share of the audience and
the share of the audience's was based
with the Nielsen they used to have
little boxes on as a percentage of
television that share was based on how
many TVs were sold and we had a lead in
show that came before us called Three's
Company which was very popular was
really popular so we were also very
lucky to have that lead-in for our for
our show our first show and if you can
imagine that on a Monday I walk around
and everything was like you know normal
Tuesday night the 60% of the people that
had televisions were watching the show I
mean it's mind-blowing now if you're
like you know why do sunny you know if
you get a you a share that's like it's
like nothing compared to that or any any
show there so modernized now there's so
many different places for you to get
entertainment that the share was like
this little band it was only there were
only three walking down the street
supermarkets LOUIE LOUIE LOUIE it was so
it was just the power of this so we
sunny in philadelphia from the very
beginning with those guys and Caitlyn
with Charlie and Glenn and Rob we hit it
off right away
they had done eight shows and I watched
the shows I'm friends with John Landgraf
who runs the affects who we used to be
my partner at Jersey television and I
saw the show and I thought it was really
really terrific and I loved the whole
style of it they write all the scripts
but we get to screw around you know in
between and right from the very
beginning and I'm a little older than
they are I was the the you know the dad
of sweet Dan you know Dennis of course
my wife was a war but did that fit in
later on but I raised them anyway
never never and look at how what upright
standing its citizens they are right now
because they've been you know mentored
by Frank anyway from the very beginning
with all of them we became like really
close and I feel like they're my family
you can't beat that because when you go
to work everyday and you have people who
you love and you care about it's like
being on the set with your buddies you
know the kind of radical crazy stuff you
know where they slimy or they throw me
out of when i'm kami black I was a
shadow like hiding in a corner you know
it was really cool the idea is that you
know going into the makeup trailer and
getting puffed up like them for max show
when he came out you know all that stuff
is like I did that stuff obviously like
all the parts that I like to play we all
have masks you know and I figure that
you know with Frank that's a certain
mask like in the movie I'm doing now
with the you know in Jumanji it's a it's
a certain thing all the movies you do
but when you get to sit in a chair like
in Batman Returns you get to sit in a
chair for three hours and have some
artists like mess you up it's like
really cool it's like when you know when
you put on a costume where you go again
Halloween or anything like that it's
kind of you have this freedom you know
that's really really cool so all the
shows that we have done that we're a
little bit out in the stratosphere those
are my favorites when I read the scripts
and I say wow this is gonna be a fun one
you know to do yeah Frank Frank Frank
and take your clothes off and come out
of a couch yeah
yes yeah my rum hand which is very good
by the way if you soak
ham and rum it's very good it's not good
for the pig but it's rude yeah there are
tattoos I've seen of people you know
what kind of I mean I I i think the
trashman is like him I guess rum ham is
good too I remembered that day we shot
the rum ham was like really great we
were in that raft oh man and the ham got
out and it was floating away it was like
so cool stop being so dramatic man throw
on from the train was an ramsey rest of
soul she was like the icing on the cake
Billy Crystal came to me with stew
Silver's script and he said you know
would you like to play Owen and at that
time I was just like kind of feeling
Mike I wanted to direct so I did I've
done a couple of taxis I did some short
films in this done yeah they I said yeah
I'll play on if you let me direct the
movie because I really have a feeling
for this and they went for it now we
looked everywhere for leg mama
I mean I looked you know casting I mean
just couldn't find it and all of a
sudden one day and Ramsey who I had
worked with on on another movie but had
had this like some problems with her
physically she had some operations and
she had some cancer taken out and when
she walked into my office and recognized
her I swear to God nobody even give me a
big hug and then I want to hold it it's
an it's like my
yeah I had to salt $10 she was talking
like this and I said don't move stay
right where you are and I went in Billy
Crystal and Larry president's office and
I said you got to come with me mama it's
my office she was so amazing and
game-like do anything we did all kinds
of green screen and stuff and we owned
on the upside down and we had a ball and
she was like it was so much fun
[Music]
Billy's a good really dear friend and
and we had we had lots and lots of one
give you everything he just gives you
you know more and more and more it's fun
that friends who you you know you you
love to work with and it's also you can
take a little bit of license and abuse
them a little that's good
gets to your friends what are you gonna
do I've done it Michael Douglas I've
done it with Jack I've done it with him
and we're still friends so it's cool
winds Arnold my man my good man
he's a good friend we had a ball doing
that that was out of left field kind of
thing the first time I met him I have
three children now at two at the time
the two girls and I was in New York and
I was like you know full of like diaper
bags and all kinds of I was getting out
of a car I remember it late which I was
going to a hotel in New York this was
before we did twins right and I was
struggling I guess with coming out of
the car and I thought it was a doorman
helping me and the guys just come on
Danny
yeah and it was Arnold I though it's
like now he took everything with me then
we help the three was cut to the chase
somebody called me and said would you
like to do a movie with Arlo be his twin
now I think that was Ivan Reitman and I
said absolutely you know it's really fun
I like contrasts I like you know all
kinds of like wacky things and that was
beautiful
[Music]
look okay look better let's put it that
way
you know you know we have to do tools we
gotta work on the way you're walking a
little bit for you little stiff you know
you see Frankenstein I read the book
that's not gonna help you see when you
walk you gotta walk like you're moving
to music you know I don't need a
military watch I'd be like you know
Aretha Franklin and Otis Redding Wilson
Pickett a couple of white people he's
like really you know plays a lot of
practical jokes and stuff you know I'm
always on a diet I've been on a diet
since I was 10 and he liked it and he
you know what I'm doing the movie he
knew I was like trying to lose weight
and actually had a big gym and we would
go and I do like 15 minutes at level 4
on the cycle thing and he'd do like you
know half hour 11:14 you know something
and then we'd go to my trailer and we'd
have a little light and I'd do the thing
like we're gonna really light lunch of
salad and try to like you know really
good and then 10 minutes later somebody
would walk in with a little all kind of
gooey desserts that he is trying to
tempt me with and I succumbed as you can
tell and returns lovely wonderful it was
a great Batman Returns also wonderful to
do work with Tim Burton I've worked with
him four or five times now it's like
really it's a great relationship but
Batman Returns our first it was really
terrific his vision is like you know
beyond beyond he's an artist everything
in the movie that you see basically was
done he he draws everything to a really
good artist he draws everything he
showed me the penguin boy and then we
talked about all kinds of great stuff
about the penguin being thrown away by
his parents and the whole idea of the
basket floating down that
when to where the Penguins are to us
that was the birth canal and the penguin
was actually being born into the world
that he wound up living in he's a bird
fly understood and come on dreaming away
[Music]
I had V meal who is a wonderful makeup
artist and all the great people who are
supporting me in the look of the penguin
and also the material was very operatic
I like gone big you know Kevin like some
wound to move and the penguin Oswald
gave me all that I've spent three hours
in the morning just go I used to watch
films in those days before you were born
there was a we put the TV on the back
and I'd be there's the mirror and she
would be doing my makeup and I would
watch TV I would watch movies in the in
the mirror so almost all the movies that
I'd watch were backwards like people
entered from the left or entered from
the I always saw him backwards and of
course I could never watch films with
subtitles let's
old Mattila one of my favorites when my
kids were younger and the girls and the
boy was we were just starting to read
picture books like the crystal on
hallsburg and no Jumanji I mean all the
picture books and then we started moving
into chapter books and they brought me
this book that I had never heard of it's
called Matilda by Roald on and so I read
the book and it was like mind blowing
and I said I'd love to make this into a
movie do you make money do you have a
job can't you some good cars dad listen
you a little wiseacre
I'm smart you're dumb I'm big you're
little I'm right you're wrong and
there's nothing you can do about it
little dark little twisted you know
these these rotten parents have raised
this kid it was like really special
which we all try to find the special
things inside of us and I found that
they were already thinking about it they
did something was really in the mix and
then casting the Trunchbull was like
great she was like again the way I look
for mama I looked like everywhere and
then one day I got a tape from England
from the Midlands and she just nailed it
man and nailed a trench war scary really
good kids love her I dig it I really
like it because I map out everything
might do so all my movies that I've
directed
I have already Irene Oh generally kind
of sketchy what they're gonna how
they're gonna be and then I you know
insert myself and you live with it so
much as a director you know that that's
like a thing that you you're constantly
imagining what the what the thing is
gonna be like but it's it's a trip I'm
it's really fun are
when you have kids the idea is that you
want to be on Sesame Street you want to
do animated movies you want to see what
their reaction is - yeah I loved doing
Philip Tottie's too old to get mixed up
in this stuff again but if I don't
become a true hero I'll never be able to
rejoin my father Zeus hold it
Zeus is your father right mr. lightning
bolts read me a book would you dad dad
once upon a time it's the truth please I
did I don't remember
did I say oh my god I felt I must have
thought I was in a shower yeah I don't
know how was it oh good what do they
what I sing can you do it
really come on try what is it
over here I've been out to pound my own
[ __ ]
[Music]
but you need an advisor a state of
adviser a good merchandiser knowing I
can't I can't remember that experience
but like I said I really enjoy being
thrown into stuff you know so that you
know if you're there and somebody says I
probably you know don't remember but it
probably was in the script I just liked
it when it when things come out of left
field LA Confidential
I got beat up I got killed
iodine named Russell Crowe beat Academy
he's really bad guy no he's a good guy
this is the thing about working with
people who have a vision Curtis Hanson
that vision of LA Confidential I
remember when I first met with him he
had just you know folds folders and
folders of still pictures from the era
you know exactly like what he wanted the
movie to look like and there were
characters in it you felt like you know
you could emulate you could just get
into it's almost like the Ouija photos
of you know the great photographers of
the day it really was a pathway into the
movie so you get get the you get the
texture and the feeling of what what he
wanted and it was a lot of fun I mean oh
you know what yeah I mean I'm like I
don't know it's like scrolling around
and having a good time pushing the
envelope if I can it's fun to do a
comedy it's good to be serious mix it up
for a budgets
Lucy's an actress who she's in the
budgets and she asked me to come and see
a play at the ensemble Studio Theatre a
few many years ago it was a one-act play
I went to see it
David Margulis was in it when we came
out of the play she said this is a great
subject it's a great relationship is a
great par for you you want to
so I said you know let's think about it
and talk about it and the the guy Josh
cockle who wrote the play we talked to
him and we just figured why not let's
have some fun
we loved doing it Josh wrote a great
screenplay and and David and I played
the parts and we just had a good time
doing hello dummy you in a wheelchair
and a tuxedo it took me two hours to put
the on with you in a wheelchair or
surgery and he had of the editor let's
not make a big production yeah it's just
three days and my son Jake produced it
and I I went and found location was a
funny story because I said I found the
perfect apartment and the woman is
willing to let us use it right and he
said where is it and I said where it was
and we went over there and all the
apartments are the same in the building
I picked one on the fourth floor so has
a filmmaking you know what I mean you
understand
equipment you know what I mean in in New
York so you go oh why didn't you pick
the one it's exact same apartment once I
said we were gonna do it there there was
no way I could say to the woman you know
we're not gonna use it so I I said
that's so there you go that's what you
do you look these things around don't
they
what are you doing then let's live
together Rafi or whatever time we got
left
marry me why don't you
holy wow it's legal now why shouldn't we
do knew about this yeah a little has a
paddock to munch the next level
the idea of me working with Dwayne the
rock and all these everybody in it it
was it was so I saw the first movie I
dug it so much Jake Kasdan who directed
it I knew when he was a little kid he's
to come by they hand his dad and his mom
and the brother would come by and hang
out with the kids they lived at the
beach and he said would you do it I said
oh my god yeah this is it sounded like
you know the cast has so much fun so I
want to be part of it and the part is
like yeah it's really a fun part you
know I get to head through the hip work
you know play old I am old but I mean I
get to be on it's really fun working
with Danny Glover's
really it was a exciting thing for me
grandpa Anthony this is a Martha and
Bethany this is a grandfather meet you
morning sort of bargain on you you're
not barred he's barging my little Walker
yeah did you guys see Spencer Vicki went
back in we gotta go
[Music]
I had so much fun making the movie again
it's like one of those things with a
little family comes together and then
you you know you you bust apart but now
we're back together again it's really
fun I just saw the movie a day I loved
it and I think he's a great job really
exciting and and 1ups the the other
movie which was good but this one here
is even better